[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
SPEAKER: How you doing?
How you doing?
Thank you so much
for being here.
Guys, have a seat.
Let's chat.
AMANDLA STENBERG: I know this
is Google because we're miked.
SPEAKER: Right?
GEORGE TILLMAN: Right.
SPEAKER: You're miked.
All this tech is here.
The cameras are all set up.
It's, you know, a Googly place.
[LAUGHING]
So, first of all, welcome
to Google Chicago.
We are so excited to
have you guys here.
This movie is incredible.
Um, I guess I really shouldn't
be saying welcome to Chicago
for you, because you are
kind of a Chicago guy.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yep.
I lived here 11 years.
SPEAKER: Incredible.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yep.
SPEAKER: And you loved it here.
I mean, obviously, you've
done some amazing work
around Chicago stories, right?
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah
SPEAKER: "Soul
Food," "Barbershop."
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yep.
"Row Bounce."
SPEAKER: Right?
GEORGE TILLMAN: I did about--
at least about six,
seven movies here.
Actually, one thing I'm very
proud of with my business
partner, Bob Teitel
when Obama was here,
you know, he actually greenlit
the tax incentive for film.
So we were one of
the first major guys
to allow movies to come to
Chicago, with a nice discount
for a filmmaker.
So I was really proud of that.
SPEAKER: How wild is that?
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: That's just
incredible to me.
And so one of the things that
I see as a consistent theme
through some of your
films is the fact
that you have a penchant
for telling stories
about the culture.
All sides of the culture, right?
You know, you get your sadness.
You get your happiness.
You get the joy.
And that's a lot of what we
get in "The Hate U Give."
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah
SPEAKER: So tell me what about
this book and this screenplay
drew you to it.
Why did you want to tell
this story specifically?
GEORGE TILLMAN:
Yeah, what I really
love about it was
it was specifically
about the culture, about this
young girl and her family.
You know, the ideal of
navigating between the two
worlds.
So the ideal of her
struggling, and then
that being a compromised
when she witnessed
the shooting of her
best friend, I just
thought that was an
interesting character arc.
But what I love is how the
family's always center.
And no matter tough
things get, no matter
how people in the neighborhood
tell her not to say anything
about this shooting,
or how much pressure
she feels from the
police department,
and how much pressure she
feels from her white friends,
her white private
school, she just pushes,
and it makes the film
has this emotional roller
coaster, where you're going
through all these emotions.
That's what I really
imagined, envisioned
for the movie when I talked
to Angie, because her book was
very amazing.
But what I really love is how--
which I find really
significant--
is that you can tell a movie
about this specific culture,
but it could be for everyone.
And you can do it in
a way where you're not
compromising who we are.
And I think that's the key.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
And that's one of the things
that was the most beautiful
about it.
I mean, it's the
kind of movie that
can speak to a
range of audiences
and really welcomes them
in with open arms, which
is so incredible and
hard to do, I think.
So Amandla, for you, what
brought you to this movie?
So I hear that
you signed on even
before the book was published.
You were all in, ready to go.
This was for you.
[LAUGHING]
How did you make that decision?
What connected you
to Starr's story?
AMANDLA STENBERG: What
connected me to the story
was the book by Angie Thomas.
And if you haven't read it, I
highly recommend that you do,
because it is so beautiful.
SPEAKER: Second that.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah.
I was immediately
just blown away
by this story and the
power that it had in
depicting a nuanced
experience of blackness
in a contemporary world.
I feel like not
often are we afforded
those sorts of representations.
And so it was really
exhilarating to me
to see this girl who was
code switching, you know,
who is presenting
herself differently
in different spaces.
SPEAKER: Right.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And then the
way in which she's galvanized
towards activism because of
these really tragic events
that we've often
become desensitized to.
So to see those placed
in a personal narrative,
and to understand the power of
instilling empathy in people
through that, that's what
really drew me to it.
SPEAKER: And so you
mentioned code switching.
And that's a term that's kind of
gaining more and more attention
as people are trying
to understand what
it is to be a person
of color in two
different spaces in the world,
a white space and a black space.
Can you explain
a little bit more
about that, and how
Starr sees herself
code switching in the movie,
the specific situations
that she feels that she
needs to make that change?
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah, sure.
So code switching
is entering spaces
that you're not necessarily
fully accepted into,
and so understanding that the
way that you present yourself
in that space might be a
little different from how
you are in your most
authentic environment,
because you understand
that if you present
as authentically as
you are, it could
be detrimental to your
success, unfortunately,
or you could be further
alienated or isolated, which is
something that everyone does.
You know, when you're
at home, you're
probably a little
different than who
you are at work or at school.
But Starr is really
caught in this dichotomy--
which I actually
experienced as well--
of growing up in a
neighborhood that
is black and has a lot less
privilege than the neighborhood
that the kids at
her school are from,
because she goes to this school
an hour and half across town
that's mostly white.
And so she's one of the
only black students there,
and she does a lot of
self-policing because she knows
that these kids don't understand
her experience of blackness,
don't understand her community,
or who she is, or her culture.
And so she figures out how
to adjust to that environment
in order to be more accepted.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And so the way
that that manifests in the film
is she has Starr Version
1 and Starr Version 2.
And when I first read it in
the book, it really just--
it registered in a
way that I had never
seen it depicted, like in any
sort of piece of media before.
Whereas Starr describes
the experience
of feeling and hearing
your voice change.
When you enter a space that
you're not most comfortable in,
or at least when you enter
a white space in which you
understand that your blackness
will not be understood--
SPEAKER: Right, right.
AMANDLA STENBERG: So I
really connected to that,
and this whole idea of Starr
being kind of canonized by her
peers at school as an
accessible black girl,
as a nonthreatening
black girl, as a
not-like-other-black-people
black girl
SPEAKER: Oh, Starr,
you're different.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
You're different.
You're not like them.
Which is just so
kind of invalidating
and simplifies our
existence in a way
that's really detrimental.
So it was so
exhilarating to me to see
a portrayal of a black
girl that was actually
reflective of our
experiences and that
was really expansive and all
encompassing and multifaceted.
Because oftentimes,
you know, we're
only given a certain
amount of tropes
that we're allowed to play.
SPEAKER: It's a
little box sometimes.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
There's a little box.
Yeah.
We can play the humor.
We can play the pain.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
But not often is it
that we get to be
everything, and so that's
what was so exhilarating
about reading this character.
You're right, in the
unpublished manuscript.
It wasn't out yet.
But it was floating
around, because people
were so excited about it.
And I attached really early on.
SPEAKER: Your heart
latched on, for sure.
AMANDLA STENBERG: My heart
latched on for dear life.
SPEAKER: Which is great.
That says something
about the work, for sure.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah.
Another thing that I
kind of want to discuss--
I mean, it's super,
super timely.
Obviously, police
brutality is on the top
of mind for so many people,
and especially here in Chicago
with the case of Laquan
McDonald, Jason Van Dyke just
being convicted for his murder.
What is the importance
of a movie like this,
landing at this time?
You know, there's
never a right time
to talk about the hard things.
But it seems like this is
almost healing in a way,
for this movie to happen
right now, as some things are
changing in America.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Mm-hm.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just felt
like, you know,
I was just telling Amandla, like
we were in Atlanta last week,
and we finished this screening,
and someone tapped me
on my shoulder, and I
turned around, and asked,
can we take a picture?
And I was like, yeah,
we can take a picture.
And they were like, thank
you so much for the movie.
And they said, we're the
family of Emmett Till.
And I was like, you know,
just kind of blowing me away.
It was the whole family,
like six of them.
And I just think back to Emmett
Till, being here from Chicago,
going down to Mississippi.
You know, he had sort
of the talk early,
because his mom was telling him
how to act down in Mississippi,
and how to conduct yourself is
a little different from down
there.
So that talk is something that
you progress over the years.
It probably was started
through slavery, you know,
when we were free, and how do
you act around certain people?
So I just felt like it was very
important for other cultures
to be able to recognize and see
that the talk to some people
is like the birds and the bees.
But for us, for
African-Americans, or people
of color, it's a difference.
So in a young girl like
Starr, just have to navigate
and keep pushing through.
She's very much of
the world, and know
how to interact and know how
to move inside her [INAUDIBLE]
world.
But she has another-- we
have these other things
almost as well.
So a lot of that is just to let
people, as Angie was saying,
who wrote the book, is to have
empathy what people go through,
and also recognizing how
did these things happen.
And the shooting of the cop, why
did he react the way he react?
We talked about that.
And we see it from a black
cop perspective with Common.
And we'll see,
sometimes, there's not
that much of a difference.
So when you think about that,
it has to be the system.
The system.
How do they teach cops?
Who were in charge?
Who are the leaders
inside those departments?
And we don't condemn.
We just show what
the reality is,
so we can cause conversation.
SPEAKER: I thought Common's
character, Uncle Carlos,
was so unique.
Like you were saying,
you don't often
get the perspective
of a black cop.
I mean, it's such an
interesting situation
to be in where you see what
the people are going through.
You understand.
You're part of the culture.
And then, also being
kind of on the other side
of, these are your coworkers,
these are your colleagues,
and how do you speak up.
So--
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: He's so
nuanced in that way.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
And it's true.
I mean, let's say all
of us in this room,
we all have it inside of us.
I mean, let's just take
Common's character, myself, like
as an African American man,
and it's a conversation
that we have had in rehearsals.
If I'm walking on the
south side of Chicago,
if I'm by myself,
African American man,
and if I see three African
American guys walking
on the other side of street,
and they walk over here,
I'm gonna think something's up.
I'm gonna move over
across the street.
So that's that own
internal racism
that I have within myself
within my own culture.
So that has to be broken.
That's what Common realizes
when this young girl, Starr,
confronts him.
And those are the
kind of dialogues
that the movie brings up.
SPEAKER: Right.
GEORGE TILLMAN: You
know what I mean?
On both sides.
SPEAKER: And it's
beautifully done.
AMANDLA STENBERG: I think
Angie's intention with the book
was to present these
topics and these issues
in a way that was inclusive of
different perspectives, that
didn't further perpetuate a
divisiveness, that grounded it
in humanity.
And like, we always get
asked about the timeliness
of this project.
The thing is, it's been
timely for a really long time.
SPEAKER: Always timely.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And
unfortunately, will probably
be timely for a while.
But we always get asked
this also really interesting
question.
And I think last night, we
got asked it, which was,
what is the role of an
artist in social movements?
Like, what is the
role of the filmmaker?
You know, when is
it time to make art,
and then when is it time
to get up and go out
in the streets in protest?
And I think they're
so interconnected,
and both are so invaluable.
SPEAKER: They work
off of each other.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah.
And when they work off of
each other, as you know, like,
art has always been one of
the driving forces or conduits
for social movements.
SPEAKER: Absolutely
AMANDLA STENBERG:
Like they, you know,
have like a really beautiful
symbiotic relationship.
And so, I think that was the
driving force behind this
piece, is to make
something that,
in the midst of what feels like
chaos and what feels like times
in which things are postulated
as so black and white,
wrong versus right, me versus
you, winner versus loser,
I think it was-- it felt
important to create something
that explored it in a way that
would ground us and what makes
us most human, and understand
that every single experience is
multifaceted and requires--
in order for there to be
any sort of movement made
or any progress made,
you have to consider
even your enemy in a way
that is not one-dimensional.
SPEAKER: Right.
And it also comes
down to empathy,
like you were saying before.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And empathy.
SPEAKER: Just being able
to understand and look
at another side or perspective.
You mentioned the
humanity in this.
You know, there's so
much going on this movie.
There are so many themes.
But one of the things that
I found really interesting
is your portrayal
of the black family.
Right?
You don't get a
lot of that in TV.
I mean, we're starting to
get there a little bit more
with shows like "Blackish,"
and we're normalizing it.
But Maverick is such an
interesting character as well,
because he is this father who is
so complex, and he's done time,
and it wasn't
necessarily his fault,
but he's coming from this
one life that he had before,
and it's kind of completely
switching into a new role,
and he's being a father.
I'm interested to know, what was
the most important thing to you
when you were portraying black
masculinity and fatherhood,
and the home in this movie?
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
One of the things that
I loved, that, you know,
the perspective of having
a father in a movie
like this-- because
when I look back,
I've been making films for a
little bit, since the '90s.
SPEAKER: Little bit.
GEORGE TILLMAN: So when
you look back at it,
I say some of the African
American characters, films
that have African American
characters in it, 80%,
70% of them don't have a
father figure in the household.
It's always a single parent.
And that's not the case in the
neighborhood that I grew up in.
I had fathers next to me, to
the left or the right of me.
It was a community.
The community actually
raised everyone.
And it was always a barbershop.
Like, Mr. Lewis and
always a barbecue joint.
And like Mr. Reuben,
you know, like I
don't know if you
noticed on the wall,
it was like, he would
give kids free barbecue
if he sees their report cards.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GEORGE TILLMAN: And
that's the kind of thing,
that we want to
bring community back.
One of the main things is
I love their relationship.
It was very strong in the book,
between Mav and his daughter.
And I thought that was great.
And one of the
things I love to say
is that the family
has so much joy in it.
We have so many levels of humor.
Believe it or not, there's
a lot of humor in the movie.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
There really is.
Don't get us wrong.
GEORGE TILLMAN: There'll be a
lot of emotion, and it's fun.
You will be entertained.
But it's just issues
that we see every day.
And I really do believe that the
film is an entertaining venue.
That's why people pay
to go see movies--
to be entertained.
But the movie has that, but
you'll be able to relate to it,
because there's the family.
And no matter all
these obstacles,
they keep pushing through.
They keep going through it.
And at end, we see
Starr has her journey.
And that's the main thing
that I'm really proud of,
that it was two parents.
They're very close.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GEORGE TILLMAN: They
talk about sex a lot.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
There really is, like,
a romantic relationship
that grounds them.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah, it
grounds them together.
SPEAKER: They're like,
there's my parent.
GEORGE TILLMAN: I just
had some memories--
I just had memories
when I was-- we
were doing a scene
in the diner, and how
the family, after
this big incident,
the family just closed their
hands again, and they prayed.
So to me, that was a
throwback to soul food,
around the dinner table,
and the food, and every--
And I'd even tell
the actors to do it.
Everybody just started
overlapping, talking
dialogue, talking about
food, eat that hot sauce,
don't put the hot sauce
on that, you better
get to those vegetables first.
All that was just, we
were family at the time.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And that's
what makes for a really
authentic storytelling, too.
And you mentioned the fun,
and the joy, and the humor,
and a lot of the things
you were shooting.
How did you guys
maintain a sense of joy?
You know, I feel like black
joy and black excellence,
black happiness, is so
important in terms of self-care.
So like, even when you're
shooting a scene that
is so heavy, that's
emotionally charged,
how do you guys kind
of come back and find
the joy in what you're doing?
AMANDLA STENBERG: Well, we
have Regina Hall on set.
SPEAKER: Right?
AMANDLA STENBERG: She is a gem.
SPEAKER: Oh, goodness.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
Man, she's hilarious.
She always brought the joy.
Always brought the humor.
I think is just our
natural inclination
to work through trauma
that way, to rely
upon our humor and our joy,
and even though this experience
was so intense and
traumatic at times,
there was always
a sense of levity,
and like always a sense
of community and family,
and a feeling that if you really
were coming up against a wall
emotionally, and you were tired,
and these events and portraying
them feel so heavy,
there is always
someone you could turn to
who would have your back.
SPEAKER: That's community
at its very finest.
And kind of having a nice
family to shoot with, really
helps with that kind of thing.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yep.
SPEAKER: Talking a little bit
more about having, you know,
having that community
and that family all
around you on set,
in the movie, I
guess Starr is trying to figure
out who her community is,
even outside of her home.
So, in her school at Williamson.
Chris is a great character.
He's really interesting,
because he's
navigating allyship,
and trying to figure out
what that means for him, how
he fits into the scene, how
he fits into Starr's life.
If you guys had to, I guess,
determine something that's
important for someone who
is trying to become an ally,
or trying to figure out how they
can get involved in movements
and civil rights
and racial equality,
what's the first step?
You know, it can
feel heavy, right,
to step into a world you're
not used to, and be like,
you know what?
I'm with them.
How do you do that?
AMANDLA STENBERG: One
of my favorite lines--
when I read it in the script,
I had this feeling of like,
retribution of like,
oh, my god, I wish
I had had this in high school.
It would've have saved me so
much like, internal strife.
But there's this scene
where Chris says to Starr,
I don't see color.
I just see a person
for who they are.
Like, I see you.
SPEAKER: Yes, yes.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
And Starr says,
if you don't see my
blackness, you don't see me.
SPEAKER: Amen.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
And that was so
validating to read on the page.
Because I think there's
this idea that in order
to be an ally, you have to
look at the other person
as your equal.
But almost as if in the
process of doing that, in order
to do that, you have to
discredit the aspects of them
that are different,
or that make them
more marginalized than
you, when really it
should be the opposite.
When you look at someone you
want to be an ally to them,
it's so important that you are
inclusive of all the aspects
of their identity
that make them them,
and see them in the way in
which those aspects of self
dictate or influence
their experience.
Because the idea of, oh, I don't
see color is, like, really,
like, it's a great intention.
SPEAKER: Of course.
AMANDLA STENBERG: For sure.
But it also like, rests
upon the assumption
that we live in a post-racial,
post-identity society.
And we all know that
that's not true.
SPEAKER: Which we would love.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
We would love that,
but that's not where we're at.
I don't even know if
it's possible for us
to be in a place that
doesn't use identity
as a lens through which we
primarily look at each other.
So I think being an ally
is about looking at someone
and not being afraid of the
discomfort, of, oh, this person
is different than me.
Their experience
different than me.
It's not about
trying to postulate
their experience
as equal to yours,
but rather like respecting it,
and all of its differences.
SPEAKER: Accepting.
Learning from.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah.
And learning about it.
And I really think
sometimes, it's
just is about shutting up--
sitting down, shutting
up, and listening.
SPEAKER: Open those ears.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yeah.
Because I think that's
what is really, you know--
when there's a group of
people who have historically
taken up a space and been
very comfortable in that,
it is very uncomfortable to
no longer take up that space,
or control it, or kind of demand
that you take up most of it.
And so, what looks
like discomfort
to people who have
historically had
privilege is often just equity.
That's what's really
essential for Chris
to understand, is he needs
to take a step back and not
take up as much space, even
in their conversations.
SPEAKER: Right.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Starr is
really assertive in making sure
that he's listening to
her and saying, actually,
this is my time to talk.
And listen to me.
SPEAKER: Here's my story.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
Here's my story.
And so, I think that's
a huge part of it,
is stepping back and
being like, oh, I'm
so used to taking up all
this space right here.
But, actually, let me step back.
I mean, draw it back in
and allow this other person
the time and the space.
I'm using the word space a lot.
The time and the space
to express themselves.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And
express their perspective.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
There's like, two people--
there's two lines in
the movie that define
that, how an ally can work.
Sabrina Carpenter plays Hailey.
And she says, who else is going
to speak up for people, girl?
And she's a white
individual saying that.
And then you got--
SPEAKER: Shook my core.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
You got K.J. Apa
who plays Chris,
and his line is, being an ally,
what do you want me to do?
What do you want me--
how can I help?
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
GEORGE TILLMAN: So that shows
the difference between the two,
that we show two
different sides.
One is about listening instead
of trying to follow somebody.
So--
SPEAKER: Being a part of it.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So one thing
that's really interesting
is, you know, as Starr is trying
to figure out whether or not
she's going to use her
voice and speak up,
I mean, we see that happening
in different ways in the world
now with, like,
hashtag activism.
Right?
So it's incredible that
we're using social media
to say their names
and to learn more
about the stories that aren't
really being told without it.
But then bringing that
into the real world
and taking another
step is very different.
So what advice do
you have for people
who are yearning to speak
out, who want to speak out,
who want to try and
do something new,
but are kind of feeling that
little bit of them that's
holding them back?
What's the first step
to opening yourself up
to trying something like that?
AMANDLA STENBERG: I really--
because I really love
approaching activism
from a place of like,
artistry and humanity.
And like, when Angie
Thomas wrote this book,
she was still in college.
She was writing it
on her lunch break.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Lunch break.
Short story, too.
AMANDLA STENBERG: It
was a short story.
You know?
She was someone who was
socially active on the internet,
but wanted to find a conduit
through which she could express
it further, take the next step.
And for her, that ended
up writing a novel.
That has now been "New York
Times" number one bestseller
for 83 weeks.
You know?
SPEAKER: Unbelievable.
AMANDLA STENBERG: I'm
not saying that's going
to happen to everyone.
But find your own lane.
But I feel like--
I don't know.
I really believe in the power
of expressing your activism
through your
artistry, and this was
such a beautiful
opportunity, because it
was this like, synchronistic,
like, beautiful thing, where
everything came
together, and we were
able to marry all of the
things that we cared about.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
AMANDLA STENBERG: And
I feel like, yeah, it's
about expressing yourself
in whatever conduit
that may be right.
SPEAKER: I think we have some
audience questions coming up
for you guys.
Two quick questions
before we hop to that.
And you guys can kind of
start lining up at the mic
if you have any questions
you want to ask.
On a lighter note, for both of
you guys, you being a Chicago
guy, having lived here
for so many years, what's
one of your favorite
places to eat in the city?
GEORGE TILLMAN: You know
what, they got one--
they have one in Atlanta,
but it's not the same.
But right down on
Wabash, you know, right
in front of Columbia College,
was Harold's Chicken.
SPEAKER: Always.
Good.
You can stop by while
you're still in town.
GEORGE TILLMAN: I
think I wanna stop by.
Can we stop by there?
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: It's a classic.
And then for you, I heard
that your Harry Potter
fandom is real.
AMANDLA STENBERG: Yes.
SPEAKER: My heart is
just skipping a beat.
So I want to know.
Nothing to do with the movie.
Just my own curiosity.
If you had a patronus,
what would it be?
AMANDLA STENBERG: Oh, my
god, that's so challenging.
SPEAKER: Take a second.
I'll start with mine.
It'd be a dolphin.
[LAUGHING]
AMANDLA STENBERG:
Damn, that's accurate.
SPEAKER: Right?
That's good, right?
AMANDLA STENBERG: I
would like to think
that mine would be like,
a deer or something,
but I feel like it would
probably be like, a mouse.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Hey they're
cute, though,
and [INAUDIBLE] real fast.
Like, you never know.
Anybody with questions, anyone
who wants to ask anything?
If not, I will keep on going.
Don't tempt me with a good time.
Do you want to step up
to the mic over here?
AUDIENCE: So my question is,
you talked about really living
this dichotomy life, growing
up from where you are,
and then having to really change
that persona when go to school.
And I think about Lakeith
Stanfield in "Sorry
to Bother You," in
the movie, and how
he switched to his white voice,
right, because he had to work,
and he had to pretty much
change his environment.
So I'm curious to
know, how have you
been able to navigate your life
in your professional career
where you might have to change
a mannerism a little bit,
and kind of juxtaposing that
with your actual environment
from where you are back home?
How are you able to
navigate through the waters
and kind of live two
different personalities?
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Challenge.
AMANDLA STENBERG:
You know, I mean,
I started going to that school
when I was 10 years old.
So for me, for a long
time, I had this idea
that there was something
wrong with code switching,
that there was
something wrong with me
for having kind of this
multi-faceted personality
that shifted depending
on who I was around.
And it kind of took me
until I was a bit older
to understand that there's
nothing wrong with that,
and that that's pretty natural,
considering the circumstances.
I used to hate that I had
to make myself smaller
or change who I was in
order to feel more accepted
into that environment.
But learning that language
of whiteness and privilege
has actually been
really invaluable to me
when it comes to
navigating Hollywood.
Who would have thunk it?
[LAUGHING]
So it's a tool.
You know, it's a tool
at the end of the day.
I don't necessarily
look at it anymore
as having to compromise myself.
I also have kind of witnessed
this shift happening,
where we are living in a culture
that is so transparently driven
by black culture and by
blackness that I'm starting
to notice that, even
in my spaces of work
within my industry, if I show
up to that space authentically
as myself, I seem to be
more accepted than I ever
have been in the past.
And there seems to
be this kind of push
for an inclusivity that is new.
And so I feel like
I have to compromise
myself less and less.
But I'm just more accepting of
all the different parts of me
and the way that they
manifest in my mannerisms,
or the way I talk.
SPEAKER: All wrapped up nicely.
Oh, thank you guys so
much for being here.
We're just honored to be able
to talk to you about this movie.
It really is such a
movement right now.
And we hope that
it's going to be
received so well
by so many people,
and seen all across the world.
And I really think
it's going to start
a lot of great conversations.
I was telling you before,
my husband and I saw it
last night.
We talked about it for
like, an hour and a half,
just chatting and
chatting and chatting.
And I think that's
one of the really,
really special things
about this movie,
is that it allows for
that conversation in such
a safe and open space, mixed
with humor, mixed with emotion,
mixed with your classic family.
And I think that's what's
really beautiful about it.
So congratulations to you both.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Guys, the movie is
out everywhere October 19.
Make sure you go out and see it.
Also, pick up Angie
Thomas's book,
which is based off of--
it's also a brilliant read.
Nice and easy all
the way through,
and just a really robust story.
And it's kind of what
inspired you guys to be here.
GEORGE TILLMAN: Yup.
And it's selected
theaters this weekend.
Selected theaters.
SPEAKER: Amen.
GEORGE TILLMAN: So you can
see it tonight in Chicago.
Right here.
Actually, right down
the street, I heard.
SPEAKER: It looks like
all of you00 all of you
just got plans, right, tonight?
Like, you don't to think about.
So, George Tillman and
Amandla Stenberg, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]